[Musique]
de l'eau à perte de vue une ressource
qui semblait infinie et qui a poussé
cette première nation à s'installer ici
elle lui a même donné son nom sa peau
tauriac en langue crie signifie
l'endroit où l'eau coule
[Musique]
mais l'abondance et la transparence ne
sont plus aujourd'hui que des apparences
la rivière geôles longtemps source
d'approvisionnement est devenu
empoisonné
pendant plus de dix ans les habitants de
la réserve ont été privés d'eau potable
une situation pourtant loin d'être isolé
[Musique]
la communauté crie de whisky s'y pique
un peu plus au sud a vécu le même
calvaire
[Musique]
une crise à laquelle s'était attaqué le
gouvernement libéral en 2015 promettant
de régler le problème en cinq ans
aujourd'hui malgré les milliards
dépensés une trentaine de communautés
autochtones au pays sont toujours forcés
de faire bouillir leur eau
photo ac fait partie des communautés
chanceuse
une usine de traitement ultra moderne
vient d'ouvrir
l'eau puisée au milieu du lac est
filtrée par osmose inverse traité est
testé en permanence un processus
contrôlé par ordinateur
s'il se dit satisfait le chef néo saint
john hayes ne peut s'empêcher de se
demander pourquoi il a fallu attendre si
longtemps on
la communauté crie voisine de wii speak
a aussi été exaucé après six ans
n'attend pas
forcément son chef est reconnaissant
envers les libéraux de justin trudeau
et en suivant l'évolution de la campagne
il avoue s'inquiéter d'une éventuelle
arrivée au pouvoir de gouvernement
conservateur pis ces désagréments
mais s'il ya maintenant de l'eau potable
à moscou ses piques il n'y a toujours
pas de courant c'est donc par la route
qu'elle est livrée dans les maisons
toujours ce camion site est en fait sa
tournée pour remplir les réservoirs
de l'eau pure sans arrière-goût et des
populations satisfait
et pourtant le chef d'astrée ne peut
chasser l'amertume qu'il ressent en
voyant le sous-développement affligeant
les premières nations
inexcusable selon lui dans un pays du g7
longtemps
craig audi a travaillé à livrer l'eau
dans la réserve
ici le problème fini par se régler il en
restera selon lui encore beaucoup d'eau
tout aussi criant
comme beaucoup ici greg se désole de
voir les jeunes générations désoeuvrés
perdre la connexion avec la terre
nourricière une terre qui change elle
aussi
[Musique]
les changements climatiques ici n'ont
rien de théorie un enjeu que les
politiciens ne prennent pas suffisamment
au sérieux selon le chef national
il lance donc un appel à plus de
modestie à plus de respect pour ma
nature
un rappel aussi nous sommes après tout
que ses passagers et nous ne sommes que
de passage
[Musique]